here let me make sure yeah our filters
are good
so happy
Monday uh let me switch this
over so
today we're going to finish something I
started late on Friday um the code was
like in a crazy mids spot but uh what
we're doing here I have a few different
contributors that have made scyon
environments at this point I'll show one
of these that I've ported so
far you can check this on
puff. so we had a contributor who made
this like this pong game really hard um
and it was sub submitted in
scyon and I ported it to Native C so
that we could compile for web assembly
there's no real performance reason to do
this um but it is very nice to be able
to have like a standalone in uh in web
assembly so that you can do this with it
so what we're going to do is we're going
to Port finish porting breakout to this
we're going to put breakout online and
then the thing that I want to also get
done this week which is going to be a
little bit harder uh right now there is
this very obnoxious pain point in that
you have to in order to go oops I
realized I don't have the chat up on
screen either uh let me fix that hey
linky but uh I realized that in order to
go from python to scon to
C it's a little bit tricky uh and there
tends to be a lot of boiler plate
associated with that so I'm going to
look for places that we can reduce and
eliminate boiler plate so that we can
just have a lot of nice clean C files
the one other thing I have not figured
out yet is whether I want each
environment to be a pure single file c
stand alone or if I want to share some
render and utility tools um I kind of
like the idea of having each environment
be self-contained because
like in my head like yeah they're
probably some common utilities that I
could factor out and then it would be
it's kind of cool right cuz like oh yeah
you can use puffer for this stuff but I
think that the correct design decision
is probably going to be to make these
completely or almost entirely uh
independent the one thing that we will
reuse are the custom uh the neural net
architecture code because that's a
little tricky to redo every time and see
but yeah we're going to start with this
today
and we'll see where this goes
stuff this is what I had started on
yesterday or Friday uh this is like a
very quick hacky Port of the game
and I'm pretty sure this just seg fault
so let's go fix
that uh right so there was like a whole
bunch of stuff that I guess I just
didn't Port
yeah so I I remember now there was like
this really obnoxious thing uh where the
signatures are gigantic this is one of
the things that we're going to have to
fix but essentially this is an artifact
of having to have bindings for Python
syon and C is you get these really
obnoxious call signatures uh this is one
of the things we're going to end up
having to figure out how to fix but for
now I think all I have to do
is probably need to go pull up the the
scon code for
this yeah so here's Noah's original code
Noah is a contributor to puffer so when
this is done we're going to put on this
and pong we're going to put attribution
to the original uh the devs of the scon
versions
you know it'll be like code by so and so
forth by
me yeah you can see this ridiculous
signature
right they're like a
wrap yeah we'll just we'll side by side
it CU basically we just need this to
have the same
signature yeah look at that
so uh I don't know why the order is
wrong so we're going to
do float
DT frame
Skip and
then the allocate function you can skip
all the numpy stuff the design of this
is such
that so you have an init function and an
allocate function and they are different
and the reason for that is that the
allocate function has to construct all
these buffers
um but when you create a a Breakout game
from python you actually do all the
memory allocations in Python and you
pass that memory into c as a buffer and
the reason for that is that means you
have shared memory across Python and c
and then if you do that then you can get
transparent access to all the state data
of the game in uh in Python and in C so
you get this nice mirrored effect that
said I don't think that this is the way
to do it this is just like way too much
stuff to pass this probably should be
like one big contiguous struct or
something uh but we will figure that out
later welcome YouTube
folks okay so rewards scores episodic
returns uh the first thing here that we
need
is counters numb agents where did num
substeps come
awkward yeah I don't know what this is
but we don't need
this oh hey
Noah well welcome I'm porting your stuff
um yeah I if you I don't know if you're
around here but I'm going to show you
exactly how I'm going to manage all this
stuff today and I'm going to come up
with some cool ways to uh to improve on
this cuz actually this is not just a u
problem I've had this problem with my
stuff as well and uh I think we're going
to do some cool design to get around
this today but yeah you're going to have
your Breakout game online and playable
on puffer GG today so that's probably
pretty cool right
and like I told you not to worry about
it because like I said uh I I told you I
would like just do this stuff and help
fix stuff on stream and that's what I'm
doing promise
kept for folks watching if you submit uh
environment code like if you're going to
submit like some of the other Atari
games or like other environments I will
do this with you as well and you'll get
to see how this type of stuff
works can't stay very long as I have it
work and no worries the VOD will be up
if you want to see this stuff later and
so will the final
code but absolutely thank you for the uh
the environment here it's going to be
really cool to have Ultra fast break out
I also think that the uh the
vectorization while like internal
vectorization was a cool idea initially
I think it only makes sense for
environments that are actually natively
multi-agent um I think what we're going
to do is we're going to have we're going
to have each environment only have the
one agent but then we're going to
parallelize in C so we'll have like you
know uh we'll have a way to allocate
like the array of environments in C so
that you can do step vectorized
operation but uh you don't have to have
the logic of the M itself have that
extra Dimension cuz that extra Dimension
is pretty
gross really doesn't do anything for
cash
cercy really doesn't help you with very
much I could be wrong about that we'll
say it doesn't degrade performance I
think it'll only degrade performance if
you put that whole Loop in Python uh I
think that if you just have like the
loop over environments in C
you should be
fine oh yeah the other big idea I had
lately that uh I just talked with
somebody who would really like it if we
had this um I don't want to commit to
this just yet but I'm thinking that I
might do a custom memory allocator for
uh all the environments in puffer lib
where it just gives you a Big Blob of
memory right and then it takes the
memory segments that it needs for each
individual piece of data out of that
because what that would let you do is it
would let you do um really fast State
reset and set operations which would
allow you to do like MCTS and stuff
incredibly incredibly quickly because
essentially set state is just mem copy
at that
point that was the other idea I had
recently well to be fair I've had that
one for a while but um you know I just
thought about it I just started
considering it seriously just now based
on a meeting I had
so
63 uh assuming
here nit C
breakout
[Music]
actions I think this is actions is
unsigned charar
recently um the Raab Dev rayon said that
he wished that uh C didn't have C didn't
have signed versus unsigned types just
everything was signed and maybe we have
an extra type for
bites I thought about it and he's
totally
exist there should be numb
balls
signature we'll get this right now and
then we'll simplify
it so this
scores episode
returns we don't have numb balls
instar number of
balls then we get paddle
positions uh ball positions
all velocities brick
positions brick
fired the wall positions yeah so I guess
the signature just got messed up somehow
when I
ported uh wall positions then we do
paddle widths paddle
Heights uh ball speeds is not
here ball speeds hit
counters um agents width height ball
width ball
height brick width brick height OB
size no bricks yeah there you
go that that's the whole
death P
Heights I guess did I miss one here
are there actually any industry jobs in
reinforcement
learning of
course yes
like also um being in any area of ml you
can be in any other area of ml in like a
month like if I wanted to be working on
like if I wanted to be working on
Transformers
uh on that side of things it would
literally take me a month to catch up
with all of the latest literature from
the past several years and to just be
doing that it's like the exact same set
of
skills
um but yeah there's like a lot of stuff
in robotics there's some random stuff in
Industry as well like there's some like
random stuff in like optimization of
layouts and
whatnot it's not like nobody does RL I
mean like if you think about it right
like you're not solving every problem
with a 400 billion parameter model that
you can only access via an
API that only knows about language and
can't like adapt quickly to new not
unintuitive problems right that's what
RL is for
did I not pass width and height
somehow I could have sworn I did oh
right here it's
missing ridiculously Long Function
signatures
and then okay so right here I just have
to call this correctly
so we have oops
P frame
actions uh observations right yeah that
exists
Rewards or I'm just checking to make
sure each of these
exists on
balls did we not allocate number of
balls
yeah we didn't allocate number of balls
here pic
nums pattle
positions all
speeds hit counters and then numb agents
gets passed in this is correct with
height all All Height brick width and
brick
height of
size
bricks row calls didn't you define done
twice
uh duns looks like you are
correct let's apparently this is
unsigned Char as well good
catch yeah this function signature is
way too long to keep track of basically
like half of this stuff is going to end
up getting packed into a um like a game
state struct or something
uh
okay Falls
int and
actions is is supposed to be unsign
float and then these are just defined in
the wrong
order uh usually what we do here is cuz
this is one pass compiler I put reset
and step at the
bottom and that normally just handles
everything well I don't put it at the
all the way at the bottom I put it at
the bottom of the um the logic which is
right
pi and now we have legitimate bugs on
the port to fix float and
int hit counters I assume this is
supposed to be an INT
counters oh we double
assigned that doesn't matter but it's
weird
okay that jumps us down to
here subscripted
value Bri
positions I think this is a 2d array
right uh apparently brick positions
is a 2d
this might get set from python in the
original code
right Rick positions cuz I don't see
where this is getting
set like where are they populating
this nowhere right it would be in reset
if it would be anywhere and it's not
here so I'm assuming what this is
happening is that this is using the
python
logic I don't see it in here though oh
wait here it is right
here populate it once in python yep I
see
it
cool put this in C
this I guess
we'll make a a function somewhere
it's probably got to be up
here
this and then we just
do void uh generate brick
positions the breakout star n
oops positions and then this gets
allocated to zeros
right and I think that this now has to
be brick
positions yeah but num bricks is this
variable this is kind of awkward
actually I think the easiest
way
well it depends if I want to have this
be like a weird breakout very varant
where you can have like different
breakout games or
whatever
um probably I shouldn't be caring about
that at the
moment
so it's just kind of gross because like
with the number of bricks not being a
constant
yeah I generally don't do 2D arrays for
position Are you purposely avoiding
something like vectors yes yes I
C++ this is ultra high performance Sim
right we don't need Dynamic length we
don't need all these
things the goal is not just to implement
breakout right that's easy the goal is
to implement stupidly High performing
breakout or reinforcement
learning all the Sims have to run a bare
minimum of a a million steps per second
at the very
least we'll just
do
X continuous memory yeah in fact I want
it to be more continuous than it already
is I think eventually the way we're
going to go is we're going to have a
custom mem allocator that just gives you
one giant block of memory for your
entire Sim state so that you can very
easily set and like reset states which
would then allow you to do like MCTS and
stuff be
nice it's actually very funny to me that
like I've seen some very bizarre
functional stuff like for trying to do
this like just functional State stuff
like you don't need any of that you just
need contiguous allocated memory um and
then you can be way faster because
functional code is very
slow memory
Arena
yeah when running a sweep oh I just
realized this is not visible over my
camera there we go
when running a sweep can it happen that
the solution of hyper parameters
overfits to the set seed but doesn't
perform well for other seeds yes I'm
aware of that that is a limitation of
wand B uh not of like what I of my
Approach so w b doesn't make it as far
as I can tell w b does not make it easy
to run multiple seeds and collect data
across them so uh the way that I do it
with wand B sweeps um I don't actually
like save the model from the best run so
you end up having to retrain anyways and
it's not fully deterministic so uh you
basically end up having to reverifying
get if I may repeat a question I asked
on disc if I missed a question on
Discord my bad uh in your opinion is
carbs that much more computer efficient
that it is worth dealing with the
growing pains it may still have versus
just using
optuna uh I don't think anybody has good
optuna Integrations with RL either
unless I'm mistaken I guess actually
clean RL kind of does right clean RL
does a thing with us
optuna um it depends what algorithms
you're using from optuna carbs really
really nice because it's like it's like
this really fancy gaussian process
based thing that maintains a set of Paro
optimal points and is comput aware so it
looks for it looks for longer Solutions
as it becomes more confident in its
predictions over shorter Solutions so
it's pretty interesting um as for
whether the growing pains are worth that
that's up to you but I'm the one
currently dealing with the growing pains
right like I deal with that by
integrating with puffer so stuff doesn't
work you just let me know and I fix it
in puffer right
Noah brick positions are X and Y right
you did like X comma
Y is what it looks
why
would
this brick y yeah exra ask you're going
to ask me if I can cat up some ligma
oops I got to pay attention almost
messed up the indices
positions ah right we need to we didn't
finish porting this yet so
so this is already
allocated
uh y
offset
oops
[Music]
r or we can do row and call like
this and we have
index do you use idx here
you do use
idx call times brick width row brick
height y
offset this is good the only thing I
want to change is I want to do
this and there we
F and
all
right oh because this I was for agents
right you don't need this eye
anymore wait no this is frame skip
uh do I mess up
oops oh it is Agent ID X so we don't
care about
is this correct it's changing the uh the
loop variable in the
right where the heck did this line come
from
I think I can just delete this line I
don't know where that came
right no I think it was fine I think
that you uh you did it correct and I
probably like tabbed the dumb super
Maven
suggestion don't use llms
kids say no to
llms I swear even like the very small
amount that I use them for like saving
typing occasionally I screw up and like
tab too
yeah we're totally going to make like
some struct base State thing for this
because this is ridiculous all these
variables
okay which of these variables are
correct let's figure this
out break out
Pi 576 these ones are correct
right
so paddle
yeah it looks like these ones are
correct so we get rid of this this this
this
paddle paddle
speed there's no such thing as paddle
speed I like where the heck did these
things even come from I don't know
hardcoded the
speed well then I'll have to figure out
where I uh I'm missing
that 2 + 2 plus number x +
one OBS size 2
plus two plus
num
okay yeah so Noah the way that that uh
we should do this like when these
variables get to be ridiculous like this
the way that you're going to see that
we'll do it is we'll make a
struct in C or scon that has all the
data in it um like all of the the stuff
that has to get passed from
Python and then uh you'll have a numpy
return type basically that gives you a
numpy structured array so you'll load
the data into the numpy structured array
and then that gets unpacked from C and
that prevents you from having to have
all this intermediate garbage and it
also results in you having con is memory
for state so that's probably what we're
going to end up
doing now I don't know there are a few
things I'm not positive on how to do
with that uh I think there's a little
bit of pointer Shenanigans but we'll
figure that out
somehow DT frame skip agents withth
height uh this is backward so it's got
to be ball width ball
height wait ball
width ball
height oh I my brain just did something
weird no that's correct quick
width height OB
size I don't know why it needs no bricks
like
this
uh undefined okay
references
handle
ball
three
step t
discreet that's weird it doesn't like
this is inlined
I don't know why that
is that's fine for now
so uh LD Library path
equals Li and now I'm sure we're going
to have to debug a bunch of runtime
stuff
here
um where's the a Breakout
fault
320 paddle
uh not sure what's going on here this is
kind of a
thing let's see if there's uh do we have
input on this
yet yeah we don't have input on this so
we need
long how we do input here I think we do
like
get
is e down
it oh I think we did we do input in the
demo file right the only thing that we
do in the render is we do
this
right make or
pong.
H Spong dot I mean c yeah so you can see
we do the input right here this is how
we do the
input that's a nice way of doing
it oh interesting I actually already
have it working here and actions zero
uh okay so it's not actually working
then see why that
allocate
balls so this these allocators need to
be fixed first because that'll give me
some better
errors obervations done reward
scores
three
balls
positions
States balls fired wall paddle with
paddle height TI counters that's
it but now when I close this those three
memory leaks are system level RB always
has those um they're like below RB
itself apparently they're like in
open gel or something I don't
know but we don't have any extra memory
leaks
since I see we have a lot of folks on
YouTube
now just quick little thing for uh for
new folks
here this breakout Port is going to be
on this website later today it's a ultra
high performance breakout version for
reinforcement learning written by Noah
currently being ported by me and it's
all free and open source it is
on puffer a/p puffer lib which is right
here
all this code it's in the dev Branch at
the moment and if you want to help me
out for free go ahead and St the repo
helps me out a ton back to
right those all look correct to
me so
let's see is it actually recording
actions
okay so you can see that I'm when I
press the
buttons things
happen but nothing happens on the
screen so apparently the paddle position
doesn't get
set the bricks don't get drawn either
let me think about what could be wrong
here
reset I bet that this reset is not
getting called correctly
set what if we set this to negative one
I bet we're just not initializing
end let see do we actually get prints
here you can see we do we get all the
prints for all the bricks
right
oops and then we do print
f r position
wrong why are these wrong I called this
right here didn't
I assume something is just not getting
set correctly here one of these
variables let's see which one it
right yeah so this this call needs to go
after I initialize all the
stuff so now we see that we have correct
positions here or what look like correct
actions and it says if brick state is
one print F
brick we'll just do state
n brick colors okay apparently there are
too many
colors let's figure out what colors
we're
used red orange yellow sky blue and
blue that's easy
enough six is going to be equal
to uh
red
orange yellow green sky
blue
I also I don't know if you're still
blue I also I don't know if you're still here Noah but I really like your idea to
here Noah but I really like your idea to
make the puffer Li the ball I think
that's hilarious we're totally going to
do
that okay this did not seem to
help uh these are still not being
State okay all the states are
zero so
and see it's drawing all these different
bricks right but nothing is
right I thought that's pretty funny can
get to be a good size where you see at
the puffer while the bar ball is still
hard to
hit yeah well we'll just make the game
render bigger
right I really like that idea that's
awesome marketing so thank you for the
free
marketing I mean it takes a lot to get
um you know really specific tools like
this out there and fun stuff like that
actually goes quite a long
way you know you just have these
environments but the puffer fish is the
ball we should do it for pong as
well here's one uh one row of
bricks I don't know why the rest of them
aren't drawing let's figure that out
client there you go so not processing
the actions for some
reason and figure out why that is the
case
right okay so it's getting actions but
the substep
okay so it's moving units of zero for
some
reason .0 oh cuz this is an
INT this is
moves oh look at that wait does it
work uh nope
nope that was interesting let's play
that
again
collisions very close now though to
having it
working we'll probably put it online as
soon as it works and then we'll clean it
up after so people can play with it
positions assumedly wall positions
doesn't get
initialized yeah you can totally see
that this is
um so wall position
has six
numbers
apparently 0
Z how is this structured wall positions
actually I only need to set one of these
right it's end wall positions
of
four
one where is uh with I I
suppose I guess this is not allocated to
be big enough
right
okay here's your
game this is definitely breakout Yep
this is how breakout Works guys
it's actually hard to play because
there's like no way to tell what the
heck the ball is
doing I think it also goes through the
paddle
um we got to figure out the brick
collisions
see if someone can balance double
pendulum let me see
why is there so much stuff here for a
simple project